حماس بالنسبه لال بيبي ليست حركه
ارهابيه حركه تحرر وطني
ومقاومه الحماس والجهاد وكل الص كان سهلا
للغايه بعد الحادي عشر من سبتمبر بسبب
تنظيم القاعده والاحداث التي وقعت في
الولايات المتحده ان يتم ربط اي جماعه
اسلاميه سياسيه بفكره الارهاب وبشكل اكثر
تحديدا لم يكن هناك فرق بين الدوله
الاسلاميه والقاعده وحماس وحزب الله
والجهاد لقد وضعوا جميعا في الصندوق نفسه
صندوق الاسلام العربي الارهابي الان اذا
فهمت اصول هذه الحركات واذا قرات
تصريحاتها وفهمت تطلعاتها واذا كنت تعرف
التاريخ الفلسطيني وتعرف التاريخ العربي
ستدرك انه كان هناك وبشكل دائم سواء في
فلسطين او في العالم العربي حركات علمانيه
ومجموعات يساريه وكذلك كانت هناك هناك
دوما حركات ومجموعات اسلاميه سياسيه لقد
تم انهاء الحكم الملكي في مصر من قبل
تحالف مكون من الاخوان المسلمين والضباط
الاحرار كذلك الجزائر تم تحريرها من قبل
الجماعات الاسلاميه مع جبهه التحرير
الوطني التي لم تكن جماعه اسلاميه لذلك
فان حقيقه وجود جماعه اسلاميه في فلسطين
يقابلها وجود فتح والجبهه الشعبيه والجبهه
الديمقراطيه في جهه اليسار هي حاله طبيعيه
في كل نضالات التحرر في العالم العربي لان
كثيرا من الناس في العالم العربي مسلمون
متدينون كما ان كثيرا من الناس يعتقدون ان
الاسلام هو ايضا جزء من النضال بعض الناس
لا يتفقون معهم والبعض الاخر يتفق معهم
ولكن هذا لا يحولهم الى ارهابيين وهذا
يعني ان حركه التحرير الفلسطينيه لم تكن
كيانا واحدا وهذا الامر ينسحب على كل
حركات التحرر في العالم
[موسيقى]
ت